واضح ان الشهيدين كان في حاله استرخاء
يتناولان الطعام هذه الاغراض الشخصيه
للشهيدين
[موسيقى]
اخبار العالم باعجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم تصعيد اسرائيلي جديد في
الضفه الغربيه الاحتلال يعدم فلسطين في
نابلس بعد اشتباكات مع مسلحين ونابلس تشيع
شهيديها وسط اجواء من الغضب والتنديد
بجرائم الاحتلال ومجلس الامن يعقد جلسه
مشاورات مغلقه لبحث الاوضاع في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه وزيره الخزانه الامريكيه تتعهد
من بيدجين بمحاربه ما وصفته بالممارسات
الاقتصاديه غير العادله للصين معربه عن
الامل في عدم ترك الخلافات تتسبب بتدهور
العلاقات بين البلدين في حين قال رئيس
الوزراء الصيني انه ينظر الى الجانب
المشرق رغم العقبات في وجه العلاقات مع
واشنطن تويتر تهدد بمقادات شركه ميتا بسبب
منصتها الجديده
وتتهمها بتعيين موظفنا السابقين
بالقدره على الوصول الى اسرار التجاريه
وغيرها من المعلومات السريه للغايه لدى
تويتر ومتحدث باسم ميتا ينفي ساين لازاله
الهواجز بشان دورها روبوتات الذكاء
الاصطناعي تعقد مؤتمرا صحفيا والاول من
نوعه في جناف افتتاح اعمال القمه العالميه
للذكاء الاصطناعي حيث اجابت على اسئله
الصحفيين بشان تاثيرها على فرص البشر في
الحصول على وظائفه مشيره الى انها تنشد
الخير للبشريه الى اللقاء